there's news now out of minnesota a case
that sparked significant consternation
controversy and
involvement from nfl players last year
after the death of george floyd on the
streets of minneapolis not far from u.s
bank stadium on memorial day it started
a summer that was violent that was
impactful that was revolutionary in many
ways and now derek chauvin the officer
prosecuted for the death of george floyd
guilty on multiple counts manslaughter
second degree murder third degree murder
all three counts guilty prosecutors did
not seek first degree murder charges
that requires premeditation in this
instance difficult to prove that at any
point before
killing george floyd he intended to kill
george floyd all the other charges
guilty guilty guilty
a case where shireen
and the justice system is premised on
creating a very high bar
beyond a reasonable doubt the goal is to
to ensure that innocent people don't
wrongfully go to jail and the system
favors
ten
guilty men going free over one innocent
man wrongfully going to prison that's
what makes it so hard to get convictions
in this case the evidence was there and
despite the defense doing everything
they could to create reasonable doubt
the jury in 11 hours of deliberation
finding derrick chauvin guilty on all
counts in the murder of george floyd and
there are people who would get upset
when i would call it a murder last year
the jury's now spoken folks
it was a murder
absolutely mike i don't know how you
watch that video
it's just appalling and not agree with
with what this jury has decided i mean
it's this is one of those days one of
those times we're gonna remember where
we were when we heard the news right i'm
gonna remember sitting here and hearing
it from you for the first time just like
we did in the oj simpson case and and so
many others uh through the years there's
a handful of them and this is one of
those days we're going to remember mike
where we were
and i'm glad you mentioned the o.j
simpson case because that case is a
prime example of the american standard
of justice that is premised on
protecting the individual from a
wrongful incarceration to the point
where
if you have the resources to compile a
dream team of lawyers you can create
reasonable doubt out of thin air out of
a glove that doesn't fit even if it
really did fit that's how easy it is now
it's not easy if you don't have the
money and the problem is there are
plenty of innocent people who can't
afford competent legal counsel and do
end up behind bars but
it just shows
that to get that conviction even when
you've got the death of george floyd on
tape and i watched plenty of this trial
they brought up every possible
alternative explanation for the death of
george floyd and that was the way that
the law applied in minnesota that if you
could show it was heart disease if you
could show it was hypertension if you
could show that it was reaction to
whatever drug was found in his system
that that would exonerate derek shelvin
for
that extended period of time where he
had a knee on george floyd's neck and
his hands in his pocket that's
that's the part of it that was always
the most chilling to me and that's the
image that i always think of shireen the
shot of chauvin nonchalantly
killing george floyd with his hands in
his pockets
and
justice is done
and it will be a lengthy prison sentence
for derek shoving now there's always
potential for appeal we heard yesterday
the possibility for
a mistrial that was rejected but it does
become one of the points the comments of
congress person maxine waters to the
extent that it pierced through the jury
sequestration that's an item that can be
taken to an appeals court this won't be
over any time soon and when you're
talking about a man's liberty
you you expect all the steps to be
followed all the appeals to be exhausted
but the verdict is critical the verdict
is important and uh everyone was paying
attention for this one and throughout
the nfl world and beyond the the verdict
in derek chauvin guilty on all three
counts difficult to pivot back to
football after that but we will be
watching for any statements from teams
like the vikings the national football
league sent a memo yesterday internally
to employees about this looming verdict
so we'll be watching for reaction from
throughout the football world to this
verdict but again derek shoving guilty
on all counts in the murder of george
floyd
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports